new restaurant specializes in long
wieners watch out world the male
equivalent of Hooters is ready for
business
Ashley named tallywackers the dining
establishment is a bar staffed by
half-naked men serving phallic-shaped
foods such as hot dogs although the
restaurant is located in a predominantly
gay neighborhood several women have
already voiced their enthusiasm for the
idea on the company's Facebook page I
haven't been here but I think this is an
amazing idea women enjoy looking at
scenic views to tallywackers expected to
open in Dallas just in time for Mother's
Day it seems pretty clear to me that
this is going to be all gay guys I don't
sense women really going you're a woman
Felicia will women be attending this
place a lot of bachelorette parties
going in huh
God is a good across the chest yes so
you would go Paul do you think there's
any chance something like this can
actually work of course what do the
stupidest things in the world work of
course chances to work yeah this will
probably go great who knows it'll work
for a wild new work I don't know look
restaurants are tough anyway regardless
of what's hanging out of people's shirts
and pants yeah who knows the restaurant
business it could go bad for a lot of
reasons but you know I think it's
hilarious actually I think it's really
funny do you go to Hooters I you know I
go to Hooters yeah when it's the only
thing open and I'm walking this I don't
know if you ever worked Stanford and
Sons in Kansas City
no but it's actually in Hooters Plaza ah
which is I believe the cultural center
of Kansas City and yeah you just go
around the corner and have some great
chicken wings and all right so it'll
just if eclis go to Hooters for the
hooting so it's not necessarily for the
booze yeah I don't I don't care who's
serving me if the food is good and the
service is good I don't give a [ __ ] get
me chips yeah how do girls feel about
who have you Brandi
somewhere that they were gonna have a
Hooters Airlines I think they were at
one time and I don't know that it
actually happy it had something is that
why is that supposed to mean like a
penis and some kind of subtle like
language is that slave is it I think
there's some subtle is there something's
a leeway when you get down to it when
you get down to the logistics of who
will allow you to advertisers but you
can't go on with like schlong Meister I
like that I think if it is if it is in
the gay neighborhoods and it is going to
focus on the gay market they're gonna
have to turn the lights down really low
yeah and maybe put holes in the tables
and the side walls and things and then
then you've got an interesting franchise
uh would you guys go to tallywackers do
you like the footlong hot dog let us
know other comments right